I was really dying when you sent me the recording of the duck that you encountered on your run. And you, the duck's quacking, and Connor's doing very bad duck sound effects. I thought that was a decent duck quack. Quack. Quack. Quack. Quack. Quack. Quack. Quack.
当你发给我那个你在跑步时遇到的鸭子的录音时，我真的是笑得快死过去了。还有你、鸭子的叫声，以及康纳（Connor）那非常糟糕的鸭子音效。我觉得那鸭叫还挺像那么回事的。嘎嘎。嘎嘎。嘎嘎。嘎嘎。嘎嘎。嘎嘎。嘎嘎。
Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 47 recorded on October 3rd, 2021. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about my favorite topic at the moment, combinatory logic, and we talk about some combinator birds and real birds as well. You should teach me some stuff about combinators or something because... Oh, while we wait for Dave? Is Dave coming? Have we heard from him? I have not heard from Dave.
欢迎来到 ADSP，这是录制于 2021 年 10 月 3 日的第 47 期播客节目。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持布莱斯（Bryce）将聊聊我目前最喜欢的话题——组合逻辑（combinatory logic），我们还会聊到一些组合子鸟类（combinator birds）以及真正的鸟类。你该教我一些关于组合子的东西或者别的什么，因为……哦，在我们等戴夫（Dave）的时候？戴夫要来吗？我们听到他的消息了吗？我没听到过戴夫的消息。
So... Oh man, do we want to do like a mini combinators episode until Dave shows up? If Dave shows up? I think so. I think so. Okay, here we go. Teach me master.
所以……哦天哪，在戴夫出现之前，我们要不要做一个迷你的组合子主题节目？如果戴夫来的话？我想是的。我想是的。好吧，我们开始吧。请教我，大师。
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy, oh boy. So some of you may have already seen the talk that I uploaded and premiered on YouTube on October 2nd. There was a digression in the midst of that talk that covered the history of combinatory logic. But where do I want to start? So one, you can go watch that talk if you are interested afterwards. I've also, on the most recent episode of Arraycast, my other podcast, I go on like a 10 or 15-minute ramble about how combinatory logic and combinators have led to the most beautiful code that I've ever seen in my life.
天哪，天哪，天哪，天哪。所以你们有些人可能已经看过我在 10 月 2 日上传并在 YouTube 上首播的演讲了。在那场演讲中间有一个题外话，涵盖了组合逻辑的历史。但我想从哪里开始呢？所以第一，如果你感兴趣，事后可以去观看那场演讲。我还曾在我的另一个播客 Arraycast 的最新一期节目中，花了大约 10 或 15 分钟东拉西扯，谈论组合逻辑和组合子是如何催生出我这辈子见过的最美妙的代码的。
But yeah, let's start with the history, a mini history of combinatory logic. The year is 1924. My main guy, my guy, Moses Schoenfinkel, real sad story. He had like a health problems, ended up dying pretty young. But before he did that, he managed to publish one paper on his own, another with a co-author. And that one paper was called On the Building Blocks of Mathematical Logic. And my guy, Moses Schoenfinkel, introduces five combinators, I, C, and S, two others that don't really matter, T and Z, but C would later be renamed the K combinator, and I, K, and S, for those of you that are in the know, are the three combinators that make up the S-K-I combinator calculus.
不过好吧，让我们从历史开始，一部组合逻辑的迷你历史。时间是 1924 年。我的好兄弟，我的铁子，摩西·勋菲尔德（Moses Schoenfinkel），一个挺悲伤的故事。他身体有些健康问题，最后很年轻就去世了。但在那之前，他设法独立发表了一篇论文，另一篇与人合著。那篇论文叫做《论数理逻辑的构件》（On the Building Blocks of Mathematical Logic）。而我的好兄弟摩西·勋菲尔德引入了五个组合子：I、C 和 S，还有另外两个其实不太重要的 T 和 Z，但 C 后来被重命名为 K 组合子；对于你们这些懂行的人来说，I、K 和 S 就是构成 S-K-I 组合子演算（S-K-I combinator calculus）的三种组合子。
We'll get to that in a sec. This is 1924. Five years later, a guy named Haskell Curry, some of you may or may not have heard of him. The Haskell is from Haskell and the Curry is from Curry. No big deal. He rediscovers combinatory logic and also discovers that Sean Finkel had this paper in 24
我们一会儿就会讲到那个。这是 1924 年。五年后，有个叫哈斯凯尔·柯里（Haskell Curry）的人，你们中有些人可能听说过他，也可能没听说过。编程语言 Haskell 就是取自 Haskell 这个名字，而柯里化（Curry）则取自 Curry。这没什么大不了的。他重新发现了组合逻辑，并且还发现勋菲尔德在 24 年就发表过这篇论文
that introduces these combinators. So his paper, I believe, is called An Analysis of Substitution Logic or something like that. And that is one of his first papers that will lead to two or three decades of research on what ultimately is going to be called combinatory logic. And he publishes, Haskell Curry, that is, publishes a seminal text, which is volume one of a two-volume book, textbook with, I believe the first volume is authored with Robert Faze, who I actually don't know who that is, but co-authors should get mentioned.
其中引入了这些组合子。所以他的那篇论文，我记不清了，好像叫《代入逻辑分析》（An Analysis of Substitution Logic）或者类似的名字。那是他的首批论文之一，这将带来长达两三年的研究，最终被称为组合逻辑。而且他——也就是哈斯凯尔·柯里——出版了一本开创性的著作，这是一部两卷本图书的第一卷，教材的合著者，我其实不太认识，第一卷好像是与罗伯特·费兹（Robert Faze）合著的，但合著者理应被提及。
And this is basically, it's an untyped, simple lambda calculus. So everyone's heard of lambda calculus, but like, at least to me, a lot less people have heard of this S-K-I combinator calculus or combinator logic. And all you actually need to have a Turing complete language is S and K. I is expressible in terms of S and K. Okay, but hang on, hang on, hang on. What is a combinator? A combinator, in my opinion, is a composition pattern. They're all just functions, higher order functions.
这基本上就是一种无类型的、简单的微积分（lambda calculus）。所以每个人都听说过 lambda 演算，但至少对我来说，听说过这个 S-K-I 组合子演算或组合逻辑的人要少得多。而要拥有一个图灵完备的语言，你实际上只需要 S 和 K。I 可以用 S 和 K 来表达。好吧，但是等等，等等，等等。什么是组合子？在我看来，组合子就是一个组合模式。它们其实全都是函数，高阶函数。
Some of them don't really express, quote unquote, composition patterns, such as the I combinator, because the I combinator is just the identity function. For those of you that have not heard of the identity function, it's a function that takes a single argument and returns you back that argument. When I first heard of the identity function, I thought, that sounds stupid. Why would you ever need that? And admittedly, I think that's a very reasonable reaction to have to a function that literally just returns you what you pass into it. But if it's so useless, why did it show up in C++20? Well, you need it for composition, right? You know, if you're going to plug into some other higher order function. Yes, there are many higher order functions. And just in case there are some non-functional programmers that have, are not super familiar with the term, a higher order
它们中的一些并没有真正表达所谓的“组合模式”，比如 I 组合子，因为 I 组合子就是恒等函数（identity function）。对于那些没听过恒等函数的人来说，它是一个接收单个参数并原封不动将该参数返回给你的函数。我第一次听到恒等函数时，我想，这听起来太蠢了。你为什么会需要这个？无可否认，我对一个字面意义上只返回你传给它的东西的函数做出这种反应是非常合理的。但如果它这么没用，为什么它会出现在 C++20 中呢？嗯，因为组合需要它，对吧？你知道的，如果你要接入其他一些高阶函数的话。是的，有很多高阶函数。以防有些非函数式程序员对这个术语并不是超级熟悉，高阶
function is just a regular function, but it can take a function as an argument or return a function. So it's just a function that takes other functions or returns functions. Great examples of these, sort of, if you use sort of a little hand wavy, is like all of the std algorithms, you know, std accumulate. Any algorithm that can be customized with a function object or a lambda, you can consider as kind of a higher order function. It's not, you know, by the book definition, because, you know, things decay to pointers and blah, blah, blah. But the equivalence of these in other languages like Haskell and functional languages, those are all higher order functions versus a function like, you know, plus that just adds two numbers together. That is not a higher order function. It takes sort of data as arguments. So all of these combinators, so S, K, and I, I can describe, S is a little complicated, but I and K
函数其实就是一个常规函数，但它可以把函数作为参数或返回一个函数。所以它就是一个接收其他函数或返回函数的函数。这类函数的绝佳例子，如果你用一种比较模糊的说法的话，就像所有的 std 算法，你知道的，std accumulate。任何可以用函数对象或 lambda 进行自定义的算法，你都可以认为它是一种高阶函数。它不完全符合（教科书上的定义），因为你知道的，有些东西会退化为指针，等等等等。但在其他语言如 Haskell 和函数式语言中，这些与之等价的东西全都是高阶函数；而像诸如 plus 这种只是把两个数字加在一起的函数，那就不是高阶函数。它接收的是某种数据作为参数。所以所有这些组合子，比如 S、K 和 I，我可以描述它们——S 有点复杂，但 I 和 K
are super easy to describe. So I takes a single argument. It's a unary function. Just returns you what you passed in. K takes, it's a binary function, takes two arguments and just returns you the first one. So it throws away the second argument. Also seems a tiny bit useless, but these things become very important. And S is what is known as the most powerful combinator of all. In fact, Stephen Wolfram, for those of you that are following that guy, Mathematica, he has the combinator challenge out right now.
超级容易描述。所以 I 接收单个参数。它是一个一元函数。只是把你传进去的东西返回给你。K 接收一个二元函数，接收两个参数，并且只返回第一个参数。所以它丢掉了第二个参数。看起来也有一点点无用，但这些东西变得非常重要。而 S 就是被称为所有组合子中最强大的一个。事实上，史蒂芬·沃尔夫勒姆（Stephen Wolfram），对于那些关注那个家伙（《Mathematica》的作者）的人来说，他现在正发起一个组合子挑战赛。
He literally just launched it two weeks ago. And it's $20,000 to anybody that can show that the S combinator on its own is universally, is computationally universal, whatever that means. I don't actually think, initially, I thought that meant that like you, you know, that means Turing complete. So S and K are shown to be Turing complete just on their own. I thought he was asking to just so that S is Turing complete, but I don't think computationally universal is the same as Turing complete. But S, what S is, is it is a function that takes three arguments, basically a binary function, a unary function, and an argument.
他就在两周前刚刚推出了这个活动。任何能证明 S 组合子本身具有通用性、计算通用性（无论这意味着什么）的人，就能获得 20,000 美元奖励。我其实一开始并不认为……我一开始以为那意味着你，你知道的，那意味着图灵完备。所以 S 和 K 已经被证明单凭自身就是图灵完备的。我以为他是要求证明 S 是图灵完备的，但我不认为计算通用性等同于图灵完备。不过 S，S 是什么呢？它是一个接收三个参数的函数，基本上是一个二元函数、一个一元函数和一个参数。
And the composition pattern there is you take your argument, pass it to the unary function, and then you take the result of that evaluation along with the original argument again, and pass those as two arguments to the binary function. So that is a little bit of something to digest like mentally, but a really easy example is, which I think we've talked about this on the podcast before, is palindrome. So if you want to check, is this string or is this vector of numbers palindromic? If you reverse it, is it the same thing? So your
而那里的组合模式是：你拿到你的参数，把它传给一元函数，然后你把该求值的结果连同最初的参数再次一起，作为两个参数传给那个二元函数。所以这在精神上有点需要消化，但一个非常简单的例子——我想我们以前在播客里聊过这个——就是回文（palindrome）。所以如果你想检查，这个字符串或这个数字向量是不是回文？如果你把它反转，它还是原来的东西吗？所以你的
unary function is reverse, and C++, literally, it's stood reverse. Your binary function is stood equal, checking to whether a string or a list are the same thing. And the composition pattern then is you reverse the string or the vector, and then you take that reverse string with your initial string, pass those to stood equal, and if they're the same, you know that you have a palindrome. So that's a very, very simple example of where you can use the S combinator. And very interestingly, in the J language, which is the second array programming language that Ken Iverson worked on after APL,
一元函数是 reverse（反转），在 C++ 里字面意思就是 std::reverse。你的二元函数是 std::equal（等于），用来检查字符串或列表是否相同。而组合模式就是：你反转字符串或向量，然后把那个反转后的字符串和你的初始字符串一起传给 std::equal，如果它们相同，你就知道你得到了一个回文。所以这是一个非常非常简单的例子，展示了你可以在哪里使用 S 组合子。非常有趣的是，在 J 语言中（这是肯·艾verson（Ken Iverson）在 APL 之后工作的第二个数组编程语言），
two juxtaposed functions form the S combinator. And they call that a hook because of sort of the pattern which i'm not going to get into and that is different from apl where two juxtaposed functions is the b combinator okay explain what you mean by juxtaposed just like side by side so literally like in in j equal stood equal the equivalent of stood equal is a verb or a function called match, which is hyphen colon. So in J they have digraphs. So two ASCII symbols. So the equivalent of stood equal is hyphen colon and reverse is pipe period. So when you put those next to each other with the binary function first and the unary function second, literally without doing anything else that automatically forms an S combinator, which they call a hook. Whereas an APL, if you put those same functions next to each other,
两个并置的函数就构成了 S 组合子。他们称这为“钩”（hook），因为某种模式——我不会深入展开——这与 APL 不同，在 APL 中，两个并置的函数是 B 组合子。好吧，解释一下你所说的“并置”是什么意思？就像并排摆放一样。所以字面意思，在 J 语言中，equal，std::equal 的等价物是一个名为 match（匹配）的动词或函数，写作连字符冒号（hyphen colon）。所以在 J 中他们有双字符（digraphs）。也就是两个 ASCII 符号。所以 std::equal 的等价物是连字符冒号，而 reverse 是管道句号（pipe period）。所以当你把它们紧挨着摆放，二元函数在前，一元函数在后，字面意思上不需要做任何其他事情，这就自动形成了一个 S 组合子，他们称之为 hook（钩）。而在 APL 中，如果你把相同的函数紧挨着摆放，
it's not going to evaluate correctly because it forms the B combinator, which if you're a Haskell programmer is just the dot composition operator, which is you take two unary functions, you first evaluate the first one, and then you take the result of that and pass it to the second function. So like very, if you want to add one to a number and then multiply it by two, you can do, you know, one plus x, and then your second thing, you do two times x, and you just evaluate those in order. So it's very interesting that APL uses the B combinator for what they call two trains, which is just two juxtaposed functions, whereas in J, they use the S combinator. And super interestingly, so J was developed in the early 90s. There's a paper by Roger Hooey, who was the main implementer that worked with Ken Iverson on J, that he published in 2006. And he called it hook conjunctions question mark, and basically asserts that after
它将无法正确求值，因为它构成了 B 组合子。如果你是一个 Haskell 程序员，这其实就是点组合操作符（dot composition operator），也就是你取两个一元函数，首先对第一个函数求值，然后取其结果传给第二个函数。所以，如果你想给一个数字加一然后乘以二，你可以做，你知道的，`1 + x`，然后你的第二步，做 `2 * x`，你只要按顺序对它们求值就行了。所以非常有趣的是，APL 对他们所谓的“双列车”（two trains，也就是两个并置的函数）使用 B 组合子，而在 J 语言中，他们使用 S 组合子。超级有趣的是，J 语言开发于 90 年代初。罗杰·胡伊（Roger Hooey）发表了一篇论文，他是与肯·艾verson在 J 语言上合作的主要实现者，他在 2006 年发表了这篇论文。他将其命名为“钩连接词问号”（hook conjunctions question mark），基本上断言：在经历了
17 years of experience using the S combinator for two juxtaposed functions, he thinks that that was a mistake. Because in APL, they have the three train, and Jay also has this, so that's when you have three juxtaposed functions, that forms what's called a fork or an S prime combinator. And it's very, very similar to the S combinator, but the S combinator takes a binary function, a unary function, and your argument. An S prime combinator takes one binary function and two unary functions. And it has the exact same pattern, but where we passed the original argument as the second argument for the S combinator, you basically have the initial argument, you apply the unary function, each unary function to that initial argument, and then take the results of both of those and
拥有17年使用S组合子处理两个并排函数的经验后，他认为那是一个错误。因为在APL中，他们有三函数链（three train），J语言也有这个，所以当你把三个函数并排放在一起时，就形成了所谓的“分叉”（fork）或S撇组合子。它与S组合子非常非常相似，但S组合子接受一个二元函数、一个一元函数以及你的参数。而S撇组合子接受一个二元函数和两个一元函数。它们的模式完全相同，不过在S组合子中我们把原始参数作为第二个参数传递，而在S撇中，你基本上是将初始参数分别代入这两个一元函数中，然后将这两个一元函数的结果
pass them to the binary function. So in order to define reverse, or sorry, is palindrome using an S prime combinator, you just need to, for that second unary operation, use the I combinator, use the identity function. So just like pass along the original one. And so basically, he was pointing out that this S prime combinator, it's the more general version of the S combinator. So as soon as you have the S prime combinator, you can already spell the S combinator just with an extra one or two characters. And so it's sort of a waste. And in using two juxtaposed functions as the s combinator leads to
传给那个二元函数。所以为了使用 S' 组合子定义 reverse（或者抱歉，is palindrome），你只需要为第二个一元操作使用 I 组合子，使用恒等函数。也就是直接把原来的参数传过去。所以基本上，他指出这个 S' 组合子是 S 组合子更通用的版本。所以只要你有了 S' 组合子，你只需多写一两个字符就已经可以拼出 S 组合子了。所以这有点浪费。而且使用两个并置的函数作为 S 组合子会导致
a bunch of other things that are less ideal um and i had actually always thought that but then i was like oh this is apl 2.0 ken obviously you know he had his best ideas most likely in j but the thing is is they only started experimenting with combinators in j they didn't actually have these in apl and apl dialogue apl didn't get combinators or trains until 2014. So eight years after, Roger Hooey had decided that the S combinator in J was a mistake. So yeah, S, K, I, and then, and those, the birds that correspond to those are Starling, Kestrel, and Identity, or Idiot, but I don't really like the word idiot and yeah and then there's they're just they're so it's it's i'm probably at this point i've lost like all the listeners
许多其他不太理想的情况嗯，我其实一直都是这么想的，但后来我想：哦，这是 APL 2.0，肯（Ken）显然，他最好的想法很可能都在 J 语言里，但问题是，他们只是在 J 语言中开始试验组合子，他们在 APL 中实际上并没有这些。APL、Dialogue APL 直到 2014 年才引入组合子或列车。所以是在罗杰·胡伊认定 J 语言中的 S 组合子是个错误八年之后。所以，是的，S、K、I，然后，与这些对应的鸟类是太平鸟（Starling）、茶隼（Kestrel）和恒等（Identity，或者 Idiot，但我其实不太喜欢 idiot 这个词），然后还有，它们太……所以这……我可能在这个时候已经失去了所有的听众，
by trying to explain that the s prime combinator is a more general form of the s combinator and if you have that yada yada but like it is it is so beautiful so for instance let me let me take i talked about this one briefly in the array cast episode. So for listeners of both podcasts, I apologize, but I did not approve this. You can't be like, I've already made my peace with the fact that you're cheating on me with another podcast, but you can't come in here and advertise it. Oh no. I just, uh, I mean, I can cut it out, but I won't because, hey, I'm the editor of...
因为我试图解释 S' 组合子是 S 组合子的更通用形式，如果你有那个，等等等等。但它真的——它是如此美妙。所以例如，让我——我简短地在 Arraycast 那期节目中谈过这个。所以对于两个播客的听众，我深表歉意，但我没有批准这个。你不能说——我已经接受了你在另一个播客里对我不忠的事实，但你不能跑到这里来做广告。噢不。我只是，呃，我的意思是，我可以把它剪掉，但我不会剪，因为，嘿，我是……的编辑。
So if you want to, there was a, was it a leak code or a Perl weekly challenge? One of the two. Given two lists of numbers, return true if they're disjoint, if they have no overlapping elements. Very simple problem in terms of like a problem statement. So if you're given, you know, as your first list, one, two, three, and your second list, four, five, six, that returns true because those don't have any overlapping. But if you're given one, two, you know, the list of numbers, or the elements that show up in both, and then just check is that empty. And Haskell has both of these functions, the intersect function is called intersection, and is an empty list is called null. So ideally, like, the way you can solve this without using combinators is you just, you know, in parentheses, you go, you know, if your first list is A and your second list is B,
所以如果你愿意的话，有一个，是 LeetCode 还是 Perl 每周挑战？两者之一。给定两个数字列表，如果它们是不交集的（disjoint），即没有重叠的元素，则返回 true。就问题陈述而言，这是一个非常简单的问题。所以如果给你，你知道的，作为你的第一个列表是 1, 2, 3，你的第二个列表是 4, 5, 6，这会返回 true，因为它们没有任何重叠。但如果你给定 1, 2……（中间被打断），你就得找到两个列表的交集，也就是找出同时出现在两边的元素，然后检查它是否为空。Haskell 同时拥有这两个函数，求交集的函数叫 intersect（intersection），而判断列表是否为空的函数叫 null。所以理想情况下，不用组合子的话，你可以这样解决：你只需要，你知道的，在括号里写上，
you go in parentheses, intersection AB, and then the result of that, you just pass to null. But like, I like point-free. I don't like having to state, you know, my arguments. And I also don't really like parentheses. I like reading things linearly. So how do you compose a function that takes two arguments with a function that takes one argument? In Haskell, the composition operator, the dot, it composes unary functions, a function that, you know, takes an A and returns a B and then takes a B and returns a C. You can compose those together with the dot and then get a function that takes an A as an argument and returns a C. But this one, how do you do that? So you basically can't unless if you know about the Blackbird. The Blackbird, otherwise known as the B1 Combinator.
如果你的第一个列表是 A，第二个列表是 B，你在括号里写上 `intersection A B`，然后把这个操作的结果直接传给 `null`。但我不喜欢点分（point-free）以外的风格。我不喜欢必须显式声明我的参数。而且我也不太喜欢括号。我喜欢线性地阅读代码。那么，如何将一个接收两个参数的函数与一个接收一个参数的函数组合起来呢？在 Haskell 中，组合操作符——点（dot），它组合的是一元函数，也就是一个接收 A 并返回 B、然后接收 B 并返回 C 的函数。你可以用点将它们组合在一起，得到一个接收 A 作为参数并返回 C 的函数。但对于这个，你怎么做到这一点呢？基本上你做不到，除非你知道黑鸟（Blackbird）。黑鸟，也就是 B1 组合子。
I love the B1 Combinator. It is just so awesome. It comes up all the time. And you can, if you download the data.composition module or library in Haskell, it provides you with an operator or a function that is dot colon. And that is the B1 combinator. You throw that in between null and intersection and you're good to go. What does it do? What does it do? It composes a function that takes two arguments with a function that takes one argument.
我爱 B1 组合子。它简直太棒了。它经常出现。如果你在 Haskell 中下载 `data.composition` 模块或库，它会为你提供一个操作符或函数，叫做 `dot colon`（点冒号）。这就是 B1 组合子。你把它扔在 `null` 和 `intersection` 中间，就大功告成了。它有什么用？它有什么用？它组合了一个接收两个参数的函数和一个接收一个参数的函数。
But how? It's just the mechanics. You just define it such that it performs that order of operations. And so what it does is if you put on the left side of the… Wait, wait, it feeds the binary into the urinary? So it's going to, if given a function a, that's a unary function and a function b, that's a binary function. If you, if you spell a dot colon b, aka insert the binary, the blackbird or the b1 combinator in between it, it will then construct a function that takes, that's a binary function that takes two arguments and
但是怎么做到的？这就是它的底层机制。你定义它的方式就是让它执行那种运算顺序。所以它的作用是，如果你把……等一下，等一下，它把二元函数喂进了一元函数？所以它将是，如果给定一个函数 a（这是一个一元函数）和一个函数 b（这是一个二元函数）。如果你拼写 `a dot colon b`，也就是把二元函数、黑鸟或 B1 组合子插入它们中间，它就会构建一个函数，这个函数接收……这是一个接收两个参数的二元函数，并且
first applies B, feeds those two arguments to B, evaluates it, and then feeds the result of that to A. Oh, okay. I see. So you could very simply do this in Python or C++ by just writing a function that takes, you know, two arguments uh that would either have to be templated or you can just use auto and then you know so it would be auto a auto b auto c auto d where c and d are your arguments and a and b are your functions and then you would just return a lambda that you know captures all that stuff and it basically is spelt return inside the body of the lambda, return A parentheses B parentheses C comma D, end parentheses, end parentheses, semicolon. I think I got that right.
首先应用 b，将这两个参数喂给 b 并求值，然后将该求值结果喂给 a。哦，明白了。所以你可以在 Python 或 C++ 中非常简单地做到这一点，只需写一个接收两个参数的函数，它们要么必须被模板化，要么你可以直接使用 auto，然后你知道的——所以它将是 `auto a, auto b, auto c, auto d`，其中 c 和 d 是你的参数，a 和 b 是你的函数，然后你只需返回一个 lambda，它（你知道的）捕获所有这些东西，其字面写法基本上就是在 lambda 的函数体内部返回：`return a(b(c, d))`，分号。我想我写对了。
I might have missed one end parentheses. Yeah. Whether that made sense to anybody. But anyways, these- It sort of reminds me of that extra parameter that we have on some of the range-based overloads of algorithms in C++. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
我可能漏了一个右括号。是的。不管这对外人来说是不是能听懂。但无论如何，这些——这有点让我想起我们在 C++ 算法的一些基于范围的重载上拥有的那个额外参数。哦，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的，是的。没错，没错，没错，没错。
I can't remember. What's that parameter? Yeah, projection. There we go, yeah. So what's a great example? Actually, what combinator is that? It's applying a unary function to a sequence of elements and then doing your algorithm on it. So that is... I don't actually think that specifically maps to... Well, isn't it similar to that B combinator that you just
我想不起来了。那个参数是什么？对，projection（投影）。这就对了，对。所以有什么好的例子？实际上，那是哪个组合子？它将一元函数应用到一个元素序列上，然后在此基础上执行你的算法。所以那是……我其实不觉得那具体对应到……嗯，它不就像你刚刚
described? It is, yes. I think actually that in all cases, that might be the case. I'm just trying to think that... So like, let's... The classic example of this is sort. So say you have a list of strings, and you want to sort them by length. Currently, pre-C++20, the way you're going to do that is by writing a custom comparator, a binary lambda, and then you're going to write the comparator that is doing a.size less than b.size or whatever. Or more accurately, LHS.size for left-hand side less than RHS.size. But in C++20, you can now use the projection overload to pass a member function.
描述的那个 B 组合子吗？是的，它是。我想实际上在所有情况下，可能确实如此。我只是在想——所以，让我们来看看。这方面的经典例子是 sort（排序）。假设你有一个字符串列表，你想按长度对它们进行排序。目前，在 C++20 之前，你将通过编写一个自定义比较器、一个二元 lambda 来做到这一点，然后你要写的比较器是 `a.size() < b.size()` 或者类似的东西。或者更准确地说，`LHS.size() < RHS.size()`（左手边小于右手边）。但在 C++20 中，你现在可以使用投影重载来传递一个成员函数。
So I believe the spelling of that would be like ampersand. If it's string, it's going to be std colon colon string colon colon size. I might have misspelled that. But then once you have that, it's going to basically apply that unary function. So it's very similar to a transform iterator, if you're familiar with the boost iterators or the thrust iterators and then it's going to perform the sort on that uh basically modified element so instead of comparing it on strings you're pairing it comparing it on size t's or whatever whatever that returns so i i think this is an example of like an embedded B combinator, which is,
所以我相信它的写法会像取地址符。如果是 string，它将是 `std::string::size`。我可能拼写错了。但一旦你有了这个，它基本上就会应用那个一元函数。所以这非常类似于一个 transform iterator（变换迭代器），如果你熟悉 boost 迭代器或 thrust 迭代器的话，然后它将对那个基本上被修改过的元素执行排序——所以它不是在字符串上进行比较，而是在 `size_t` 或无论该函数返回什么类型上进行比较。所以——我认为这是嵌入式 B 组合子的一个例子，也就是
although it's, it's not really though, right? Cause actually what's being performed is a custom. It's a, it's a comparator. So it's applying a binary function in the midst of this sort algorithm after applying a unary function to modify what you're doing that.
虽然它其实不是，对吧？因为实际上正在执行的是一个自定义的……它是一个比较器。所以它在这个 sort 算法的中间应用了一个二元函数，在此之前应用了一个一元函数来修改你正在操作的对象。
So it's actually, Oh, it's actually an embedded psi combinator. Wow, that's awesome. And that's what I mean is that I think for a function like a stood transform, it wouldn't really make sense to use a projection, I guess, or maybe it would. But like you could really just embed
所以它实际上是——哦，它实际上是一个嵌入式的 psi 组合子。哇，太棒了！这就是我的意思，我认为对于像 `std::transform` 这样的函数，使用投影其实没有太大意义，我猜，或者也许有意义。但你真的可以把
whatever that projection is inside your lambda that you're performing. But potentially you're doing some already custom function object that you don't want to have to create a lambda. So if you're doing that, then I don't know. There might be some use case for it. You could also, there's a range adapter. There's a views transform. So you could just pipe two of those together. Right, right, right. Yeah. But so that's
那个投影嵌入到你正在执行的 lambda 内部。但潜在地，你正在做一些现有的自定义函数对象，而你又不想必须去创建一个 lambda。如果你在那样做的话，那么我不知道。可能会有一些使用场景。你还可以，有一个范围适配器（range adapter）。有一个 `views::transform`。所以你可以把其中两个串联起来。对，对，对。是的。但关键是
the thing is in the case where you're performing a unary operation on the projected elements, it's an example of like an embedded B combinator where you're doing one unary function followed by another unary function, where it's a binary function, whether that's in the form of a custom comparator, or, you know or a binary function that returns some sort of element, that's an embedded psi combinator. So a psi combinator, P-S-I, in case I'm pronouncing that wrong, it's so awesome. It's known as ON in Haskell, where basically you apply a unary function to your two arguments to your binary function and then apply your binary function. So it's actually a specialization,
在对投影元素执行一元操作的情况下，这是一个嵌入式 B 组合子的例子，你在其中做一个一元函数，后面跟着另一个一元函数，其中它是一个二元函数——无论那是自定义比较器的形式，还是（你知道的）返回某种元素的二元函数，那都是一个嵌入式的 psi 组合子（psi combinator）。所以 psi 组合子，P-S-I，以防我发音错误，它太棒了。它在 Haskell 中被称为 ON，基本上你将一元函数应用到二元函数的两个参数上，然后应用你的二元函数。所以它实际上是一个特化，
another specialization of the S prime combinator. So the S prime combinator had a specialization in the S combinator where one of the unary functions was fixed to identity. Right. The psi combinator is a specialization of the S prime combinator where each of the unary functions is the same.
是 S' 组合子的另一个特化。所以 S' 组合子在 S 组合子中有一个特化，其中一元函数之一被固定为恒等函数。没错。psi 组合子是 S' 组合子的一个特化，其中每一个一元函数都是相同的。
So in the case of doing our, you know, sorting strings by length, that unary function is our size method. And then the binary operation is just the less than or whatever kind of sort we're doing. Ah, that's awesome. That's awesome. That's awesome.
所以在我们按长度对字符串进行排序的例子中，那个一元函数就是我们的 `size` 方法。然后二元操作就是“小于”或者我们正在做的某种排序。啊，这太棒了！这太棒了！这太棒了！
I mean, and there's this fantastic parallel, although I'm sure this exists in like everything in life, where the same way that there are the most general versions of algorithms, like stood mismatch is at the top of sort of the mismatch algorithms and stood accumulate, roughly speaking, is at the top or the bottom, you know, the root of the tree of reduction algorithms. I say sort of because most of our reduction algorithms return iterators and std accumulate returns of value. So, you know, yada yada. But so the point is, is you have these like hierarchical relationships where one algorithm is a specialization of another algorithm is a specialization of another algorithm, but can all
我的意思是，这存在一个极好的平行关系——虽然我确信这存在于生活中的方方面面——就像存在最通用版本的算法一样，比如 `std::mismatch` 处于 mismatch 算法的顶端，而大致来说，`std::accumulate` 处于 reduction（归约）算法树的顶端或底端（根部）。我之所以说“大致”，是因为我们的大多数归约算法返回迭代器，而 `std::accumulate` 返回一个值。所以，你知道的，等等等等。但重点是，你拥有这种层级关系，其中一个算法是另一个算法的特化，另一个算法又是另一个算法的特化，但它们全都可以
be traced back to std transform. The same thing exists in combinator land, like S prime combinator. I'm not sure if that's a root one but there's these sort of latent or not latent but there's like direct relationships between them where it's not i haven't read enough on the literature if they talk about how one is like the more general version of the other one but yeah i just it's it's and that's the thing is it this sounds like what did um richard park who was one of the panelists on the most recent array cast episode when he heard me and sort of others talking about tacit programming or point-free programming and using all these combinators under whatever name you want to give them, he used the word highfalutin. It sounded like, oh, like, you know, and I think there is a lot of truth. Like there is something, I think it's a valid criticism to hear someone going on and on
追溯到 `std::transform`。同样的事情也存在于组合子的世界里，比如 S' 组合子。我不确定这是否是一个根源，但它们之间存在着某种潜在的、或者说非潜在的、而是直接的关系——虽然我还没有读够相关的文献来了解他们是否讨论过其中一个如何作为另一个更通用的版本，但是的，我只是觉得——而且就是这样，这听起来像是什么，理查德·帕克（Richard Park）——他是 Arraycast 最新一期节目的嘉宾之一——当他和我有过类似经历，听到我和其他人谈论无参编程（tacit programming）或无点编程（point-free programming）并使用所有这些你愿意给它们冠以任何名称的组合子时，他用了“高深莫听”（highfalutin）这个词。听起来就像，哦，你知道的，而且我觉得这其中有很多真相。就像我觉得听到有人滔滔不绝地
about like, oh, this is so awesome. It's so beautiful. It's so elegant, but it's, it's all of this extra literature and sort of structure that you need to learn and know. But I, I think it is worth learning. And I also think that as well, you know this already, Bryce, but I think that if you were to express your programs in a point free kind of form, that is heavily relies on these combinators, the structure, the, the patterns within these composition patterns that are combinators enables a compiler to be written that can just take they can do ridiculous like ast transformations um like this is i'm not sure if i've talked about this on the podcast or it's just been in private conversations with bryce but like the fact that you know and i guess this is fixed a
谈论——哦，这太棒了！这太美了！这太优雅了，但它需要你学习和了解所有这些额外的文献和结构，这是一个有效的批评。但我确实认为它值得学习。而且我也认为，你知道的，布莱斯，你已经知道了，但我觉得如果你用一种在很大程度上依赖这些组合子的无点形式来表达你的程序，组合子所包含的结构、模式——这些作为组合子的组合模式，能够使编写编译器成为可能，而这样的编译器可以直接获取并进行荒谬的 AST（抽象语法树）转换——就像这个，我不知道我是不是在播客里谈过这个，还是只在和布莱斯的私下对话中聊过——比如你知道的（我想这在范围库中稍微修复了一点），
little bit in um with ranges but like the fact that you call you know three stood transforms in a row in c++ 11 that's three times slower than calling a single one. And like a sophisticated enough compiler that maybe removed some of the legacy of C++ should be able to see that, oh, hey, I'm calling three algorithms and those could be fused together. We shouldn't say three times slower because that's not actually correct.
你在 C++11 中连续调用了三个 `std::transform`，这比调用单个 `std::transform` 要慢三倍。一个足够老练的编译器——也许剥离了一些 C++ 的历史包袱——应该能够看出：哦，嘿，我正在调用三个算法，它们可以被融合（fused）在一起。我们不应该说“慢三倍”，因为那实际上是不正确的。
What you mean is three times more efficient. I mean, it's actually worse than three times slower. It's typically typically you're you're you're making certain this like you're making certain assumptions there it may actually be the case that um uh like i'll give you an example let's say that combining those three transforms meant that uh uh the um the that you blew up cache, right? That like when you run all three of those transform operators like consecutively on the elements,
你指的是效率高三倍。我的意思是，它实际上比慢三倍还要糟糕。通常情况下，你在那里做出了一些确定的假设——实际情况可能确实是，组合这三个 transform 意味着……呃，你的缓存被打爆了（blew up cache），对吧？就像当你连续在这些元素上运行所有这三个 transform 操作符时，
that causes you to blow out your like L1 cache. And so it's less cash efficient and so it's actually slower to combine all of those operators into a single pass than to do three separate passes right okay yes so there are going to be certain use cases where I'm sort of hand waving and making general broad statements that it won't be true for right but if well my point is you're talking about speed but you didn't actually mean speed you meant efficiency you meant you know this is a a three you know a three pass algorithm versus a one pass algorithm you meant like a you meant like a speed in like a theoretical sense you didn't mean like speed in practice like it may i mean but like in practice i feel like in actually i shouldn't speak about but i just there are many cases where
这会导致你的 L1 缓存被打爆。因此它的缓存效率较低，所以将所有这些操作符组合成单次遍历，实际上比分成三次单独遍历还要慢。哦，对，是的。所以会有一些使用场景——我在随口乱说，并做出不一定成立的广泛泛化声明——它并不总是真的。但如果……我的意思是，你在谈论速度，但你实际指的并不是速度，你指的是效率。你指的是，你知道的，这是一个三遍遍历算法与一遍遍历算法的对比。你的意思是理论意义上的速度，你指的不是实践中的速度——它可能——我的意思是，但在实践中，我觉得，事实上我不应该多说，但只是有很多情况下，
in practice it will be right right there are but there are also many cases where like like it's not something that you can just blindly do um there will be plenty of cases where it, you know, that sort of loop fusion will be less efficient. And like that's something that you have to like tune for in balance. Right. Things like register pressure, etc. Right. In general, though, for like the simple cases, you know, there's been code reviews where there's been two algorithms you know a reduction and a transform and i've spelled it you know using the correct algorithms and then the code review says this
在实践中它是对的。是的，确实有。但也有很多情况下，就像——这不是你可以盲目去做的事情。会有大量的情况，你知道的，那类循环融合（loop fusion）会效率更低。而那是你必须针对其进行调优和权衡的东西。没错。比如寄存器压力（register pressure）等。不过总的来说，对于简单的情况，你知道的，有些代码评审中出现过两个算法——一个归约和一个 transform——我把它们写成了（你知道的）使用正确的算法，然后代码评审说：“这会变慢，用 `std::for_each` 把它们合并。”然后我进行性能分析，果不其然，确实如此。这让我很难过，因为我选择了一种表达力较低的方式来……
will be slower use a stood for each and combine these and then i profile it and then you know sure enough that's the case and that makes me sad because i'm choosing the less expressive way to well why aren't you using a transform reduce uh because that doesn't that no that does not that does not work so it's it's not a transform and a reduction it's like i'm i'm doing a reduction and a transform each separately so you're doing a reduction then you're doing a transform that depends on the reduction? No, they're orthogonal to each other. Oh, I understand. But it's like you're iterating over the same data.
嗯，你为什么不用 `transform_reduce` 呢？因为那不行——不，那不行，那不管用。所以它不是一个 transform 和一个归约，而是——我是在分别做一个归约和一个 transform。所以你先做一个归约，然后做一个依赖于该归约的 transform？不，它们彼此正交。哦，我明白了。但这就像你在遍历相同的数据一样。
Yeah. And so the most expressive way to code that is just to use the correct algorithms. But if you find yourself coding two algorithms one after another, and they're operating on the same data, it is going to be faster to use what is, in my opinion, one of the worst algorithms that stood for each and sort of losing the expressivity of what you're doing, but gaining the performance. And my dream is to have a programming language that you can write it the most expressive way,
是的。所以编写这段代码最具表达力的方式就是使用正确的算法。但如果你发现自己在编写两个相继执行的算法，并且它们操作的是相同的数据，那么使用——在我看来最糟糕的算法之一——`std::for_each`，并牺牲你所做事情的表达力，但换取性能，这样会更快。我的梦想是拥有一种编程语言，你可以用最具表达力的方式编写它，
and it still be as efficient as it being sort of folded into. And that's the thing is so using these combinators, like the classic example is if you're using a S prime combinator, AKA what's known as a fork in APL to perform min max element, the equivalent min-max element. So minimum and maximum are unary operations. They take a single range and they do a reduction. And then the binary operation in this case is just like make pair. But there are many different versions of the algorithm. Like say you want to know the difference between the maximum and the minimum. Well, you just, you change your binary operation from make pair to minus, and you make sure that your maximum is on the left side of that binary operation.
而它依然能像被折叠进去那样高效。就是这样——所以使用这些组合子，比如经典例子是：如果你使用 S' 组合子（也就是 APL 中所谓的“fork（叉）”）来执行 min-max 元素（min-max element），即等效的 min-max 元素。所以最小值和最大值是一元操作。它们接收单个范围并进行归约。然后这里的二元操作就像是 `make pair`（制造对）。但该算法有许多不同的版本。比如你想知道最大值和最小值之间的差。好吧，你只需要——把你的二元操作从 `make pair` 改为减法，并确保你的最大值位于该二元操作的左侧。
If you perform like, you know, min element and then max element, you know, that will be half as efficient as the min max element because that's a single pass algorithm. Well, with this expressed in the S prime combinator, it enables, it doesn't exist because in APL I've profiled this, and it is
如果你执行类似——你知道的——`min_element` 然后 `max_element`，你知道的，那将只有 `min_max_element` 一半的效率，因为后者是一个单遍算法。好吧，如果用 S' 组合子来表达这一点，它使得……（虽然它现在不存在，因为我在 APL 中对此做过性能分析，它
roughly 260 times, or no, 2.6 times as slow or whatever efficient based on the profiling that I did. But you could hypothetically write a interpreter or compiler that recognizes that idiom and says, oh, look, we're doing two reductions. And we know that because it's the S prime combinator, it's working on the same sequence of data. So you can just bundle those binary operations into a reduction that performs both of them. And the accumulator is a pair of, you know, your two results, and poof, you know, you now have you now are able to express this as, you know, in the most expressive way possible, but you're not giving up any performance. And this is just a single example. Like on top of
大概慢了 260 倍——或者说，不，根据我做的性能分析，慢了 2.6 倍或者说效率低了多少）。但你可以假设性地编写一个解释器或编译器，识别出那种习惯用法，并说：“哦，看，我们在做两个归约。我们知道这一点，因为它是 S' 组合子，它正在相同的数据序列上工作。”所以你可以把这些二元操作捆绑到一个同时执行这两者的归约中。而累加器是一个由你的两个结果组成的 pair，然后砰，你知道的，你现在能够以尽可能最具表达力的方式表达这一点，但你没有放弃任何性能。这只是一个例子。除此之外，
that, there's a bunch of other examples. And I've actually heard someone, I need to look into this, but apparently John Backus had a language in the sixties. I don't know, I might be off by a decade, called FP, that was largely based on APL. From what from the light reading that I've done on that, that is more focused on the algebraic properties that we've discussed in the past, where like, if you know, the associativity or the commutativity, can you can you know, compile down to different parallel implementations of algorithms that can be used in this kind of compiler that I'm talking about. That, that's sort of a different thing though. That's just keeping track of, you know, if you're using a point-free, you know, operation and some reduction,
还有一堆其他的例子。我其实听说过有人——我需要查证一下——显然约翰·巴科斯（John Backus）在六十年代有一种语言（我可能记错了一个十年），叫做 FP，它很大程度上基于 APL。从我所做的浅显阅读来看，那更侧重于我们过去讨论过的代数属性，比如：如果你知道结合律或交换律，你能否编译成可用于我刚才谈论的那种编译器的、算法的不同并行实现？这、那有点不同。那只是追踪——你知道的，如果你在使用无点（point-free）操作和某种归约，
knowing at the end of the day that, oh, it's this composition of things is still both commutative and associative. Let's, let's call std reduce. Woo. Hey Dave. So, uh, what is point-free programming? Point-free programming is programming without points. That was the worst definition I've ever heard. Really? The worst? You haven't heard worse than that?
归根结底要知道：哦，这种事物的组合既满足交换律又满足结合律。让我们调用 `std::reduce`。呜。嘿，戴夫。所以，呃，什么是无点编程（point-free programming）？无点编程就是没有点的编程。这是我听过最烂的定义。真的吗？最烂？你没听过比这更烂的吗？
You used all of the term, like one of the key rules of good definition is don't define it in terms of itself. I was going to elaborate. I just wanted, I saw the opportunity for a joke and I did my best. It's very counter, or it's very confusing because in Haskell, as I've mentioned before, the B combinator, the composition operator, is the period, which is a dot or a point.
你用了所有的术语，好定义的关键规则之一就是不要用它自身来定义它。我本来打算详细阐述的。我只是看到有个开玩笑的机会，就尽力了。这非常违反直觉，或者说非常令人困惑，因为正如我之前提到的，在 Haskell 中，B 组合子——组合操作符——是一个句号（period），也就是一个点（dot 或 point）。
And when you're doing point-free programming, you're using a lot of combinators and the main combinator being the B combinator, aka the point. So point-free programming in Haskell ends up using a lot of points. And I was like, what the, what the heck? Like this doesn't seem right. But what they mean by point-free is argument-free. Point refers to the function arguments. So not having to mention the arguments explicitly. So if I want to go back to that, is this set disjoint question, one way, the non-point
当你在做无点编程时，你使用了大量的组合子，主要的组合子就是 B 组合子，也就是那个“点”。所以 Haskell 中的无点编程最终使用了很多“点”。当时我就想：什么鬼，搞什么飞机？这看起来不对劲。但他们所说的“point-free”指的是无参数（argument-free）。这里的“point”指的是函数参数。也就是不必显式提及参数。所以如果我想回到那个问题——这个集合是不交集的吗？一种方法，即非无点的……
free way to define that is to go, is disjoint AB equals null parentheses intersection AB end parentheses, and you're done. But note, I had to name the two arguments, the two lists, A and B, and those get mentioned in the solution. The point-free version is is disjoint equals null B1 combinator, aka dot colon intersection. And A and B are not mentioned anywhere. There's no arguments mentioned. And some people don't really, they don't like it. They think it's confusing. I absolutely love point-free solutions. It's the epitome of elegance in programming, in my opinion. I just realized we didn't tell Dave that he needed to record on his end. We didn't.
定义它的免费方法是去，就是不相交的AB等于空括号交集AB结束括号，这就完成了。但请注意，我不得不给这两个参数命名，也就是这两个列表A和B，它们在解决方案中被提及了。无参数（point-free）版本是is disjoint等于null B1组合子，也就是点冒号交集。而且A和B在任何地方都没有被提及。没有提及任何参数。有些人真的不喜欢它。他们觉得这很让人困惑。我绝对喜欢无参数的解决方案。在我看来，这是编程中优雅的化身。我刚刚意识到我们没有告诉戴夫他需要在他那边进行录音。我们没有。
Oh, yeah. Well, I assume. So, yeah. All right. oh yeah well i assume so yeah i all right uh you know the listener has has heard some amount of uh uh well uh we just heard from dave he popped in and uh didn't have his mic recording um so yeah that's uh dave popped his head in for a sec and is he's sorting some stuff out but yeah anyways we should i'm sorry i'm just making this super hard for you to edit. No, no, it's the best, man. I have a blast. This honestly, it's every whatever two weeks or
哦，是的。嗯，我想是的。所以，是的。好吧。哦，是的，嗯，我想是的，是的，我，好吧，呃，你知道，听众已经听过了一定数量的，呃，呃，嗯，呃，我们刚刚听到戴夫的声音，他突然出现，呃，没有打开麦克风录音，所以，是的，那是，呃，戴夫探过头来一会儿，他正在整理一些事情，但是，是的，无论如何，我们应该，我很抱歉，我只是让你很难进行剪辑。不，不，这太棒了，老兄。我玩得很开心。老实说，这就像每隔两周或者
whatever when we record, this is like, it's one of the highlights of the week. You know, what is, so I was talking to someone, this is just random tangent, but my sister was in town for the last week from Calgary. Yeah, Shannon, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It was awesome to have her around and her partner, Evan. Um, and we went to this sort of outdoor patio at one point and, uh, I ended up, well, actually he was thinking about starting a podcast and yeah, he was like asking me like, you know, like, how do you, do you like always have topics planned ahead and, uh, et cetera, et cetera. And I was like, oh, sometimes we do, sometimes we don't. Like, I mean, you want it to be really structured at the beginning. And now we just went out the window.
无论什么时候我们录音，这就像是一周的亮点之一。你知道，是什么，所以我跟一个人在聊天，这只是个随机的题外话，不过我妹妹上周从卡尔加里来城里了。对，香农，对吧？对。是的。有她和她的伴侣埃文在身边真是太棒了。嗯，我们去了一个户外露台，在某个时候，呃，我最终，其实他在考虑开始做播客，然后，是的，他就像问我，你知道的，比如，你，你是不是总是提前计划好话题，呃，等等，等等。然后我说，哦，有时我们规划，有时我们不规划。也就是说，你希望一开始时非常结构化。现在我们完全抛诸脑后了。
Yeah. We had this whole document of like, he's like, we got to brainstorm. We got to get the first, you know, 40 ideas laid out. And then I was like, honestly, when your co-host is Bryce and is as entertaining as he is. I was like, that's the key. Just find a really entertaining co-host. No, no, no. The key, Connor.
是的。我们有整整一份文件，上面写着，他就像，我们得头脑风暴。我们得把前，你知道的，40个想法列出来。然后我说，老实说，当你的联合主持人和布莱斯一样，而且像他一样有趣时。我说，那才是关键。只要找一个非常有趣的联合主持人。不，不，不。关键是，康纳。
The key is the chemistry. It's that rich, lush, luscious, Bryson Connor chemistry. That's what makes the podcast. If it was just me with some random person, it wouldn't be a podcast. That's true. That's true. Yeah, there has to be chemistry i will admit though i think between the two of us uh you definitely bring
关键是化学反应。那是那种丰富、浓郁、甘美、布莱斯和康纳式的化学反应。这才是造就这个播客的原因。如果只是我和某个随便什么人，那就不会是一个播客了。确实如此。确实如此。是的，必须得有化学反应，不过我得承认，我觉得在我们俩之间，你绝对带来了
a lot more i don't know personality or what it is but like you know the whole the whole bit last time about you being like well i do i am quite fond of waterfowl i mean that's a rare that's a rare kind of kind of you know a thing to find in someone. I was really dying when you sent me the recording of the duck that you encountered on your run. And you, the duck's quacking. And Connor's doing very bad duck sound effects. I thought that was a decent duck quack. It was pretty good.
多得多的，我不知道是个性还是什么，但是，你知道，上次关于你那种“嗯，我确实挺喜欢水禽的”整段内容，我的意思是，那是一种罕见的，那是一种在别人身上很少能发现的特点。当你把你在跑步时遇到的那只鸭子的录音发给我时，我真的快笑死了。而且你，那只鸭子在呱呱叫。而康纳正在做非常糟糕的鸭子叫声音效。我觉得那是个还不错的鸭子叫。相当不错。
It was pretty good it was pretty good yeah we got we got tons of birds you got a cpp north man you're definitely gonna have to come up and uh oh yeah should should we i mean at some point maybe we should do a live you know a live recording of this like in front of a live audience um i mean we we definitely need to record in the same room at some point um whether we would invite i don't know how i feel about i did because that's i don't know it just seems very like who do people care enough do they actually want to be oh yeah we have fans we have fans trust me i don't know i don't i don't know do we i think we have people that listen. Would they call themselves fans?
相当不错，相当不错，是的，我们有很多鸟类，你在CPP North，老兄，你绝对得来，呃，哦，对了，我们应该，我们是不是，在某个时候也许我们应该做一次现场，你知道的，现场录音，就像在现场观众面前一样，呃，我的意思是，我们绝对需要在同一个房间里录音，不管是邀请，我不知道我对此感觉如何，因为那是，我不知道，这看起来真的很像，人们会在乎吗，他们真的想来，哦，是的，我们有粉丝，我们有粉丝，相信我，我不知道，我不知道，我们有吗？我想我们有听众。他们会称自己为粉丝吗？
So there's people who listen and tolerate. But yeah. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以有听众，也有容忍听众的人。但是，是的。谢谢收听。我们希望你喜欢并度过美好的一天。这集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可留下评论。